Vous pensez que je les fais
COMMENT
mes vidéos ?
Vous imaginez que j’allume la caméra
et que je me mets à parler ?
Vous croyez que j’ai noté
quelques bullet points,
et que je les regarde
entre deux prises ?
Eh bien non !
Je lis un script
PRÉCISÉMENT
structuré.
Parce qu’À CHAQUE FOIS
que j’écris un script,
je commence TOUJOURS
par créer
LE PLAN DÉTAILLÉ.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’un BON
plan détaillé
rend la rédaction plus rigoureuse,
mais surtout…
PLUS FACILE.
Qu’est-ce qu’un plan
DÉTAILLÉ ?
Alors bien sûr,
un plan,
vous savez ce que c’est :
grand un,
grand deux,
etc.
Mais ça,
ça ne suffit pas à faire
un plan DÉTAILLÉ
— c’est comme si vous dessiniez
quatre murs
et que vous disiez :
« voici le plan de la maison ! ».
Non,
pour que le plan soit
DÉTAILLÉ,
vous avez besoin de préciser
LES DÉTAILS
de la structure
de votre argumentation.
Vous devez indiquer
les différents étages de la maison,
les différentes pièces,
et l’agencement de toutes les pièces
doit FAIRE SENS.
Bien sûr,
la qualité de votre plan détaillé
dépend de la qualité
DE VOTRE RÉFLEXION.
Et pour réfléchir EFFICACEMENT
au sujet de votre dissertation,
vous avez besoin d’une méthode
SOLIDE.
Ça tombe bien :
j’ai ce qu’il vous faut !
Inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Inscrivez-vous maintenant,
mais gardez mon cours
pour plus tard,
parce que je vais vous révéler
les DEUX CLÉS
pour faire un BON
plan détaillé.
Regardez ATTENTIVEMENT
cette vidéo jusqu’au bout,
et vous serez BIEN PLUS
efficace en dissertation
DÈS
votre prochaine épreuve.
Regardez ce plan détaillé
que j’avais fait en Prep’ENA :
vous voyez le problème ?
Eh bien,
ce plan,
il est VRAIMENT
détaillé
— et à la vérité,
BIEN TROP
détaillé.
C’est bien de détailler,
mais il faut trouver
LE BON NIVEAU
de détail.
C’est ça,
la PREMIÈRE CLÉ
pour faire un bon plan détaillé.
Alors,
une fois qu’on a dit ça,
C’EST QUOI
le BON NIVEAU
de détail ?
Moi,
je vous conseille d’aller
jusqu’à l’information ESSENTIELLE
du paragraphe.
Votre plan détaillé
doit donc préciser
L’IDÉE DIRECTRICE
de chaque paragraphe,
ainsi que
L’ÉLÉMENT DE CONNAISSANCE
qui servira à crédibiliser
l’idée directrice.
Moi,
ce que je fais
dans mes plans détaillés,
c’est que j’écris
une phrase courte,
simple
et claire,
pour présenter l’argument,
puis je précise seulement
l’élément de connaissance,
qui est souvent une référence,
entre parenthèses.
Avec ce niveau de détail,
vous voyez bien TOUTE
la structure de votre argumentation.
Si vous allez plus loin,
vous aurez TROP
de choses ;
ça vous prendra TROP
de temps,
et surtout,
vous risquez de perdre
EN RIGUEUR